hello readers this is Professor Mario
Molina a scientist who won the Nobel
Prize for chemistry now I'm gonna use
the example of Professor Molina to teach
us about connections or drawing
connections between scientific
information in a text in a piece of
writing because reading scientific
papers often involves learning about a
bunch of new information all at once and
then learning how all of that new
information connects how is information
connected before we dive into dr.
Molina's life and research let's use a
simple example a bowl of noodles say
let's put a little sauce on those
noodles maybe a little bit of pesto just
a little bit of green a little bit of
basil is a basil leaf so using this bowl
of pasta as an example in a piece of
nonfiction we can learn why something
happened we can learn why the pasta was
made you know maybe I was hungry we can
learn how something happened so in the
case of the pasta I cooked it in boiling
water and then drained it and put some
sauce on top and put it in a bowl we can
learn how one event impacted other
events let's say I had a very late lunch
at like 4:00 p.m. that consisted of this
pasta and then by 7:00 p.m. when it was
time for me to have dinner I didn't have
as much of an appetite because I'd
spoiled my appetite with his big ol bowl
of pasta at 4:00 and we can also learn
how events caused other events so say
I'd had my late lunch of pasta and I
wasn't ready for dinner at 7:00 so I
decided to push dinner back a couple of
hours that's you know I'm an adult hey
you what I want now I know this example
is a little silly but I wanted to talk
about something relatively simple like a
bowl of noodles before we dive into dr.
Molina in his research which is about
pretty complicated scientific concepts
so these are just four of the ways that
information can be connected it's not
these aren't the only four ways these
are the only ways to think about
information but these are some of them
and this is a helpful way to think about
making connections when you're reading
so this is taken from a passage on the
website about Mario Molina's research
I'm gonna read this passage and as I do
I'm going to try and find connections
between pieces of information in the
text I'm going to try and pull out of
the passage the stuff that the author
wants me to know and the stuff that the
author wants me to put together as a
professor Mario Molina tackled a
question that no other scientist had
before it was how do you
chlorofluorocarbons one a long word
chlorofluorocarbons CFCs affect the
atmosphere now this is interesting
because these are parentheses and the
parentheses are telling us that CFC is a
shorter way to refer to
chlorofluorocarbon which we assume is I
mean assume as some kind of chemical and
how do they affect the atmosphere so
what is the impact of these CFCs on the
atmosphere and specifically sentences
like these that are built up like this
right so it's the passages setting up
the idea that no other scientist had
ever asked this question or had hadn't
successfully managed to deal with it
tackled it right what is the impact of
these CFCs on the atmosphere and if you
don't know a word like atmosphere now is
a really good time to look it up right
the atmosphere is the the layer of air
and gases that surrounds the rocky part
of our planet so we can just say the air
just sort of as a rough definition so
how do CFCs affect the air and so now
we've been cued to look for some sort of
cause effect relationship now we've been
cued for some sort of relationship
between CFCs and the atmosphere they
affect it somehow they do something to
it let's keep reading CFCs are chemicals
great once used to cool refrigerators
okay so this is starting to answer my
next question like what are CFCs they
were also used in things like hair spray
so hair spray and refrigerators now I
don't use a lot of hair spray but I do
have a refrigerator in my home
which leads me to think that CFCs used
to be pretty common that's what these
two sentences together tell me I also
keyed in on the word once here which
suggests to me that they used to cool
refrigerators and they used to be used
in things like hairspray but I don't
think that they are anymore
probably because of Molina's research at
this time in the 1970s the public
believed that CFCs were safe to use all
right so now I know when this research
is taking place is in the 1970s this
also kind of explains the hairspray
thing if you've ever seen a movie from
the 70s people had a much much much
bigger hair than they do today so we
know that in the 70s the public like
everybody believed the CFCs were safe
however ooh Luva however Molina
discovered something else something else
other than what well because of where
this transition is it's in the next
paragraph and it's kind of reflecting
back on the previous sentence I think we
can say that something else is that CFCs
were maybe not so safe to use something
else was true after release CFCs rise up
into the Earth's atmosphere their solar
radiation breaks them down into
something called chlorine chlorine
destroys the ozone layer which shields
earth from the sun's harmful rays all
right so that's a lot of information all
at once and that's a lot of
relationships of information all at once
so we've got our little can of hairspray
there goes and after after it's used it
rises up into the atmosphere where rays
from the Sun hit it and that breaks it
down into chlorine and chlorine destroys
the ozone layer which protects us from
the harmful rays of the Sun so let's go
back to our pasta bowl and instead of
pasta scribble that out and replace it
with the destruction of the ozone layer
in the 70s
so why did it happen the answer to that
is CFCs got into the atmosphere you're
just gonna write CFCs atmo how did
something happen well when the CFCs get
hit by solar radiation they turn in a
chlorine and the chlorine eats the ozone
layer and what is the impact of the
ozone layer being destroyed more
exposure to solar radiation and what
caused this to happen the use of CFCs in
hair spray and refrigerators so when
you're trying to make connections in a
scientific text ask yourself these
questions why did something happen how
did it happen what are the impacts from
that thing happening and does it cause
anything else to happen taking the
information from a text and then kind of
plugging it into these questions or
these thoughts is a great way to figure
out how information relates to other
information within that passage and how
it relates to stuff you may already know
about so we say thank you dr. Molina for
saving the ozone layer you can learn
anything Dave it out